so because of traveling I've been major
major jet-lagged and that meant that
instead of waking up at 4am I actually
stayed up till 4am last night and it's
currently 7 30 and that is because I
kind of wanted to show you that you can
be productive at any time and you don't
have to wake up at a certain point or
have this perfect exercise slash
meditation routine if you kind of do
what you love and for me that is coding
and working on science I'm working on
YouTube videos like this anytime can be
a productive time even if you're majorly
jet lag and there are actually a lot of
benefits to being a night owl that I
want to discuss today such that all my
people that are night owls out of there
can see that they are also represented
so let's get straight into it so every
day actually for me I try to set one
goal that I want to accomplish within my
work and at the moment that is creating
this machine learning presentation that
I have to give quite soon for the
computational Psychiatry course and I'm
in general really nervous about this
presentation because it's the first time
I've been presenting for such a big
group but I'm also really excited so I
found I would just do that this night
and like work on this project so the
first thing I always do when I make a
presentation is make a skeleton then I
write down everything on a whiteboard I
practice the topic a bit and I do that
by speaking out loud I think a lot of
people present presentations in their
head and when they actually have to
speak they got really nervous sorry if
you have a presentation coming up I
would definitely recommend to read it
out loud and then I find the missing
pieces create a PowerPoint and usually I
create PowerPoints in latex and then I
discuss and practice it with Kali so put
down in the comments if you want to know
a little bit more about how I make
presentations so I want to give a small
tribute for all my blood there that are
night owls I think people always assume
that only morning early morning words
have really good routines and that they
accomplish a lot but actually it has
been shown that working in the evening
can actually enhance your creativity for
example and can enhance your Divergent
thinking so Divergent thinking is
evening hours have been a associated
with better the future of thinking which
is the ability to generate multiple
ideas and think outside of the box this
is critical aspects of creativity and I
definitely see online that people think
that if you wake up really early in the
morning that you magically become
productive although I see a lot lately
is this hyper optimization for certain
morning routines and I of course also
made some but in general if you wake up
three hours earlier and you exercise and
meditate and during these juices in
general you don't really get anything
done that brings you closer to the goal
you want to achieve and I do of course
appreciate if you're a parent and these
are your only hours that you have to
yourself that you take them for yourself
I don't think the morning hours are
necessarily better suited for this type
of work than the evening hours because I
think the morning hours are really
really good for hard focused work and I
noticed myself that I'm usually really
really focused in the morning but I
think the evening hours are a lot more
suited for Creative work so for example
the first time I made any type of video
for YouTube or even 5 about the idea of
youtubing it was during the evening
hours and also in general the evening
hours tend to have this lack of
distraction as well so if you stay up
past 12 no one is awake usually during
the week and this uninterrupted time is
just what I think is most important to
get anything done for progressing in
your goals so there are multiple people
that I really admire that are evening l
so for example you're from Kafka the
famous writer was known for his
nocturnal riding habits often working
late into the night on his literary
works and then you have Brandon
Sanderson I talked about him before he's
one of my favorite fantasy writers and
he says I am a Night Rider I've always
been a bit of an insomaniac and build my
pre-publication career on the back of
working a graveyard shift at the hotel
so in general what I think is just the
biggest advantage of working during the
night is that we have this big block of
time in front of us without any
constraints so usually in the morning at
least for me if I wake up really early
in the morning and I try to get a lot of
stuff done I usually have maximum three
hours that I can do any focus on the
interrupts at work or I have to wake up
even earlier but the benefit I think of
working in the night is that you could
in theory literally work through the
morning kind of what I've done today but
that's just because I'm jet lagged and
this for me is really beneficial
sometimes because if you're in the flow
or if you're working on some kind of big
project that you just want to finish and
you're really pushing yourself sometimes
it's nice if you just can continue
working instead of having to interrupt
it because you have to start the rest of
your day so something else that I
decided to do during the evening because
I was super super bored and I was
working all throughout the evening is to
have a little language class and that's
because I've been to Montreal just now
and I was really inspired to pick up my
French again and that brings us to
today's sponsor lingoda so for me
speaking a language fluently goes beyond
just speaking a language but it really
is about practicing the language with
native speakers and trying to speak as
much as possible and that's where
lingoda has been a game changer for me
so this despite my jumps packed schedule
and being super super jet lagged I could
incorporate lingola lessons into my
routine granting me valuable
interactions with native speakers which
is crucial for progression so I have
been doing that for the last few weeks
to keep up my French and if you also
want to try lingoda out for yourself
they have a lovely discount for my
subscribers so try lingoda yourself with
our seven day trial where you can take
three small group classes completely for
free and if you decide to continue then
the discount code below gives you a
discount for the first two months which
is equivalent to saving up to 200 Euros
so one thing that I've noticed with
lingoda which I really love is the
interactive part so they force you to
speak French right from your very first
class and for me I've definitely noticed
that before lingoda my language
abilities have gone down in French so
much over the last couple of months but
now that I have the ability to take up
their classes 24 7 I don't have any
excuses anymore not to speak French at
least once a week so if you're
interested in in signing up for their
classes click the link down below and
let's get straight back into the video
so after having language classes working
on my machine learning presentation and
working a little bit on the video you
see right now I decided to finish my
night slash morning routine by reading
the book The Urge which I've been highly
enjoying it's about addiction addiction
research and it's written by a
psychiatrist who himself has also
struggled with addiction so if you're
looking for any type of book to read for
the coming few weeks I would definitely
recommend this book and if you have any
recommendations of books you're
currently liking I would love to hear
them so put them down in the comments
below